il flotte un parfum de lendemain de
veille dans les restaurants et cafés de
paris mais ce n'est pas parce qu'on n'y
a fait la fête jusqu'aux petites heures
l'annoncé d'un couvre-feu imposé dès
vendredi à minuit a sonné à coup de
massue un secteur qui se demandait déjà
comment survivre il faut encore tour
penser que qu'on se retrouve à faire le
19 20 heures c'est horrible pour nous
c'est un gros manque à gagner les
nouvelles restrictions sanitaires ne
font pas le bonheur des français mais
ils sont majoritairement désigné il faut
bien faire quelque chose pour freiner la
propagation du coronavirus qui augmente
en flèche depuis quelques semaines
certains se demandent par contre si le
gouvernement ne se trompe pas de cible
je comprends pas tellement l'intérêt
aussi de conserver ces mesures dans les
restaurants ce qui va faire quand même
mourir le commerce parisien entre autres
alors que le métro l'accès au métro est
autorisé et que dans les wagons c'est
bondé
douze mille policiers seront déployés
dans les rues des neuf grandes villes
assujettis à ce couvre-feu une amende de
135 euros sera donné en cas de non
respect des consignes
au bout de trois récidive les
contrevenants pourraient écoper d'une
peine de six mois de prison et d'une
amende de 3750 euros
c'est près de 6000 $ le reste de la
france n'échappe pas complètement à ce
coup de barre du gouvernement au nom de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
toutes les fêtes privées comme les
mariages ou les soirées étudiantes qui
se tiennent dans des salles des fêtes
dans des sols polyvalente ou tout autre
établissement recevant du public seront
interdites les hôpitaux français sont au
bord du point de saturation il est
urgent d'agir a rappelé premier ministre
ceux qui forment le coeur du système
hospitalier en france sont descendus
dans la rue pour crier leur colère
aujourd'hui pas assez de moyens pas
assez de salaires est toujours pas plus
de lits en réanimation
le gouvernement a trahi ce qui était
applaudi en héros il ya quelques mois à
peine
quand aujourd'hui les gens voient que
finalement il n'y a rien qui se passe et
qu'on recommence comme avant voire pire
on n'est pas beaucoup dans les
manifestations d'une part parce que on
n'est pas assez dans les hôpitaux pour
arrêter de travailler mais aussi parce
que les gens ils manifestent en quittant
l'hôpital maintenant nous c'est ça qui
nous inquiète beaucoup
c'est qu'on a beaucoup de gens qui s'en
vont de l'hôpital ils sont dégoûtés
les primes premier aux soignants seront
versées plus tôt mais à ces critiques le
premier ministre jean castex a répondu
qu'il était faux de croire que plus de
lits dans les hôpitaux
c'était une solution selon lui la seule
vraie stratégie possible c'est le
freinage de l'épidémie par le respect
stricte des gestes barrière se marie ève
bédard radio-canada paris